Once upon a time, a donkey lived on a small farm.
He carried lots of loads every day.
But he was old and weak.
One day, he fell in the river on his way to the market.
Oh my god!
You've spoiled my flour.
The farmer was very angry and he chased his donkey away.
The donkey walked for quite a while.
Right! All the best musicians live in Bremen.
I will go to Bremen!
He sat under a tree.
Suddenly, there was a howl from the ground.
Oops! Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Never mind.
What's wrong with you?
You look so sad.
I'm too old to hunt.
My master kicked me out.
Dog, cheer up!
I'm going to Bremen to be a musician.
Will you come with me?
A musician?
Yes, I'll start a musical band.
I'll play the guitar.
That's a good idea.
I can play the drums!
The donkey and the dog set off for Bremen.